it's plastic it's most likely beige and
it sounds like this chances are if you
grew up in the United States you've
played a recorder it was a non
negotiable part of your elementary
school education and for that you can
thank this guy Carl Orff a passionate
German composer originally the recorder
was handcrafted wooden and made for the
highest of society even Vivaldi and Bach
wrote pieces for the recorder it doesn't
rely on a reed or strings just breath
it's in the flute family in the 1960s
the recorders started being produced out
of plastic cheap plastic so how did it
become the clumsy awkward sound we all
used to play that's where Orff comes in
he saw the recorder as an easy way to
get kids to start playing music the
logic was simple the recorder relies on
rhythm rather than memorization if you
can sing you most likely can play it or
if had the best of intentions to inspire
the next generation of musicians and
even though they can sometimes be
annoying our hats are off to you sir for
changing the course of music education
for generations to come